>>> I'M JUST SAYING.
BE CAREFUL OUT HERE.
YOU DON'T NEED THAT STRESS.
>> MAN, AIN'T NOBODY WORRIED
ABOUT MALIK.
IT'S GOING TO BE WHAT IT'S GOING
TO BE.
HERE COME THIS FOOL NOW.
>> WE'LL TAKE IT DOWN THE BLOCK.
I DON'T WANT TO BE INVOLVED.
>> SHONDRA!
WHAT I'D TOLD YOU ABOUT BEING ON
MY BLOCK?
>> MAN, THIS AIN'T YOUR BLOCK,
AND YOU AIN'T THE ONLY ONE
ALLOWED TO MAKE MONEY OUT HERE,
MALIK.
YOU THINK YOU CAN ROLL ME BY
YOURSELF?
>> YO, I AIN'T NEVER ALONE.
>> YOU AIN'T SAYING, NOTHING.
WHAT'S GOOD THEN?
>> OH, SO THAT'S HOW YOU WANT
IT?
>> PSH, IT'S WHATEVER, FOOL.
>> HEY.
COPS.
>> YEAH, ALL RIGHT.
YOU LUCKY IT'S HOT OUT HERE.
>> NO, YOU LUCKY.
>> WE GONNA SEE ABOUT THAT.
DON'T LET ME CATCH YOU ON THIS
BLOCK AGAIN, SHONDRA.
IT'S GOING DOWN.
>> WHATEVER.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE A PROBLEM.
[ ENGINE STALLING ]
>> HEY.
HEY, YOU'RE FLOODING IT, MAN.
>> I'M NOT.
>> SOUNDS FLOODED, BABE.
>> COME ON NOW.
[ ENGINE STARTS ]
>> THERE IT GO.
THERE IT GO.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, LIKE I SAID,
DON'T LET ME CATCH YOU ON THIS
BLOCK AGAIN, ALL RIGHT?
DON'T LET ME CATCH YOU SLIPPING.
>> YOU AIN'T EVER GOING TO CATCH
ME SLIPPING, HOMEY.
>> THAT'S ALL I GOTS TO SAY.
I'M OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ ENGINE STALLING ]
>> SO WHAT YOU THINK IT IS?
THE STARTER OR THE ALTERNATOR?
>> I DON'T KNOW, MAN, BUT THIS
BELT IS PRETTY WORN OUT.
YOU NEED TO GET IT CHANGED.
>> WELL, CAN'T YOU JUST GET IT
GOING FOR NOW?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO.
GO, GET IN THE CAR AND TRY TO
SEE IF IT WILL START.
>> ALL RIGHT.
[ ENGINE STALLING ]
[ ENGINE STARTING ]
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YEAH, MAN.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT THIS DON'T CHANGE NOTHING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IF I SEE YOU OUT HERE AGAIN.
IT'S GONNA BE A PROBLEM.
>> DUDE, IT'S SMOKING.
>> THAT'S ME?
I'M DOING THAT?
>> THAT'S YOU.
THAT'S YOU DUDE.
>> HOLD UP.
OKAY, NOW THIS IS P.
AND, THIS IS REVERSE.
AND THIS IS TWO.
NO WAIT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
PUT IT IN DRIVE, DUDE.
>> I AM PUTTING IT IN DRIVE.
>> WAIT, THAT'S "D," RIGHT?
>> MAN, YOU IS STUPID.
WHOSE CAR IS THIS?
MAN, YOU STUPID.
>> ESPECIALLY IF I CATCH YOU ON
MY BLOCK AGAIN, YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M SAYING?
>> MAN, YOU KNOW WHAT, HOMEY,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO WHAT
YOU GONNA DO BECAUSE -- AHH.
>> WHAT'S WRONG?
WHAT'S THE MATTER?
>> IT'S MY CHEST, MAN.
>> HEY, THAT'S PROBABLY YOUR
HEART.
YOU'VE GOT IT STOP IT WITH THAT
STRESS.
>> I THINK I NEED TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL, SOMEBODY CALL ME AN
AMBULANCE, MAN.
>> I CAN RUN YOU OVER THERE.
>> WHAT, NO!
NOT IN THIS RAGGEDY CAR, YOU
CAN'T EVEN GET IT STARTED.
>> MAN, AMBULANCE IS GONNA TAKE
TOO LONG.
COME ON, I'LL TAKE YOU OVER
THERE NOW.
>> YOU KNOW HE'S RIGHT.
>> YEAH, HELP ME GET HER IN THE
CAR.
>> SEE, MAN, I TOLD YOU WE
SHOULD HAVE CALLED AN AMBULANCE.
>> YEAH.
YEAH, SO YOU AIN'T THINK IT WAS
GOING TO START.
JUST HANG ON.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT MALIK?
THANKS, MAN, IF I DON'T MAKE IT.
>> COME ON MAN, DON'T TALK
CRAZY, MAN, I GOT YOU, YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ALL RIGHT.
>> DOES ANYONE SMELL GAS?
[ APPLAUSE ]